I'm a trainee at a Czech translation  unit I get to translate all kinds of  documents sometimes it's just council  minutes of meetings sometimes it's web  materials sometimes it's decisions and  inner documents for the inner use of the  council it's quite varied it was a  positive one it was my first full-time  job first time having my own office  first time having so much responsibility  and it it feels nice knowing that  somewhere out there there are documents  with my initials on them now first I  need to finish my degree in translating  and interpreting and before I do that I  also wanted to treat myself to one last  Erasmus plus experience so abroad after  this traineeship I'm going to Spain  you